you you and I were probably not gonna
see each other after this again huh
I kind of I hope that's not true I know
but I just have a feeling that but then
what chances are that but I want to see
this now probably I'll probably I'd like
to have you back on our podcast not only
that but it can you invite us to like a
barbecue or no I'm strictly professional
no would you come if I just think that
if we weren't like who you you know if
we weren't in this podcasting thing and
we don't we Prince it with our own
private lives but if you and I were like
we lived in Indiana let's just say we
lived in a Muncie some sort of lumbering
place right okay and you and I didn't
podcast at all and you were still a Jew
and I was still Korean doesn't matter
the you and I after work we'd be like
hey you want to get some brewskis
I think we're cut from the same block
yeah so but I think in because we are
who we are that we really want to come
do you guys want have a barbecue
sometime yeah so what yeah we'd love to
we're really what he doesn't like
leaving the house ever yeah okay I'll
toss and invite your way we just went to
new house we got a pool we got a spa we
got up if you have a queue you have to I
hate it it'd be weird yeah we are these
new people coming I guarantee you will
go okay 60 60 people that's what you
need to be
sorry whatever yeah yeah yeah no you can
do 10 my dad what are we doing timewise
we're over an hour wow that's amazing
you know when we have good guests it the
time flies doesn't doesn't exist it
doesn't exist there been many times I've
done this podcast ago where we've done
15 minutes do you cut it out when you
ask you know we leave it in because
that's like like I'm a thing now it's a
thing I always have to know but the
guest doesn't necessarily know it's the
things you're like what time is it
yeah yeah 15 minutes in about an hour
because he can sense it in an hour yeah
I think that's just how my incrementally
I work well in like 4050 minutes past
that I start doing the same yeah yeah
and we like our last episode went on for
three hours
oh yeah and for me that's like a night
was bad yeah I kept the enemy wrap it up
wrap it up who you will it was just us
that week oh my god you two get three
hours three hours is you we did a lot of
work prepping the show oh I don't do any
work but I like it's a different vibe
and it's good in a different way when
you just come in and have the
conversation be natural it's the friend
it's better and it's better in a
different way we keep changing it
sometimes we do that like no planning
and this time we try and like I don't
know more planning yeah yeah we don't
well when we plan we don't you loves he
thrives off of the chaotic nature and
like or even the pressure of you know
not know [ __ ] we're gonna talk about
although we have dreams we've had to
pause and where he did he hasn't slept
in two days so there's nothing coming
through yeah but the thing is is this
though is I don't care all right
mm-hmm because even when it's like
chaotic and like it's weird and I go
this
people love it know what it is it's
organic no they like the rawness that's
what we discovered when we stopped
editing it but you guys don't let me ask
you this oh did you think that this is a
good one or a bad one
I enjoyed my time here I thought there's
no what do you think I had fun do you
think it's entertaining for people I
think that I'm gonna tell you this right
now it's really good power power [ __ ]
I'll tell you I thought I just like when
you came on our podcast that we have a
wonderful natural dialogue you're very
funny guy you're quick and not sometimes
I'm not sometimes I don't even know what
I'm saying we had a very beautiful
natural yeah that we're natural that's
what I'm saying it was great but you and
I are natural we were in Nebraska we
told these no no no Deanna Mon C Mon C
Mon BR it's called cliffs
lumberyard right and it's got a red
awning all right the building does right
and it's got some sort of weird like a
mill on the logo as a logo
this is cliffs like a fantasy almost
yeah how are you can imagine it cliff is
dead this legacy real lives on and what
do we do we just hang out there and have
a couple go we saw things I saw were you
but we're gatherers we're not czars no
we've there no you know in modern day
sawing I don't know I used to have to be
cool you have to wear goggles you and I
run away and then I mean Jamie cliff
Damien got his arm chopped off and we do
and I ran away and we got fired all
right and then we went to look at some
brewskis what's the brand of the brewski
it's a local brand called it's Willy
yeah Willy love Willy Drafthouse that's
what the Clay's we go to yeah Willy's
rough house you know alternate universe
is a beautiful loving friendship right
and then you get you go hey I got some
sheets at my house oh you're a world of
drunk look every night I was like watch
the fire
the old story here it's really
interesting really kind of hole oh yeah
what do you think about that story your
house I like sheets
let's go up a beer my house all right so
I go to the house Brooklyn linen or
something I hate to do this to it these
gray sheets but I'm kind of all that
yeah yeah just perfect size for my whole
trip yeah what happens the next day is
we don't talk to each other ever again
no it ruins and then we lay then we meet
in LA do a podcast together where they
Google didn't know our history
[Music]